I am very excited about this paper. So what does
it do? Magic, according to the authors! That is,
not text to image, where we write a text
prompt and get a beautiful photo or painting,
but something else: text to 3D. Hmm…now that
would be fantastic, I would say it qualifies
as magic. We write something and out comes 3D
geometry that we can put into a video game or
any kind of virtual world. Teleconferencing.
Anything you wish. Dear Fellow Scholars,
this is Two Minute Papers with Dr. Károly
Zsolnai-Fehér. Now, wait a second. The previous,
DreamFusion technique was capable of
doing that. And this was a paper that
was published just a year ago. Now, yes, but
this one has two problems. Problem number one,
it takes a long time, and problem
number two, we still get coarse results.
Now, does this paper really have the magic they
promised? Let’s have a look together! Whoa!
Look at that difference. I immediately
see that this has so much more detail,
it has 8 times higher resolution than the previous
method. And it gets better, we noted earlier that
they are not only coarse, but slow too. The
coarseness is gone, fantastic, but I imagine
that this is now probably even slower in return.
We don’t get all this quality for free, do we?
That cannot be true. Whoa! It is not only free, it
is even twice as fast as the previous technique.
I also love the variety of objects it can conjure
up. We can even ask for more imaginative things,
like a car made out of sushi. That’s good. Now,
clearly, as all of you Fellow Scholar see right
here, this is not the quality of geometry that you
would put into those fancy triple A quality games,
but at this point I feel that we are just two
more papers away from that kind of detail.
Now, there is plenty to love here, and somehow,
it gets even better. We can even write a prompt,
and if we would like to refine the results, we can
rewrite parts of the prompt and get a very similar
result. It works great with this baby bunny, but
I’ll note that if we modify the prompt too much,
we might get an entirely different scene,
so this one requires a light touch.
And it gets even better. We can have
a collection of photos of our cat,
and then, ask the AI to create
a virtual version of this cat
but riding on a bike. Imagine meeting
your own cat in a video game! Love it.
So, when can we try it? Well, NVIDIA
is planning to include it in Picasso,
their generative AI framework, which is
hopefully going to be widely available
soon. It will be part of the Adobe suite too,
quite honestly, this will be everywhere real
soon. What a time to be alive! If you cannot
wait to give it a go, and you wish to get
notified when it becomes available, that is a
possibility through the link in the description.
And one more thing. I have surprising news.
This technique has already been surpassed. Yes,
you heard it right. The pace of progress in AI
and computer graphics research is so incredible,
that there is already something even better
than this out there. I’ll give a hint:
it is a Gaussian splatting-based technique.
I can’t wait to tell you all about it in
the next episode. Subscribe and hit
the bell icon to not miss out on it.